j'ai monté une société de location de
personnes pour répartir bonjour tu te
loue ses services à la personne c'est un
métier ça bah ouais donc à partir
bonjour tu peux te le rendre de ben
vas-y je te paie pas pour discuter et
tes parents tu vas leur dire maintenant
ces cabinets d'avocats elles sont
contentes
oui j'ai un métier superformant la fois
sur dix on prend pour une [ __ ]
ouais enfin peut-être y aller étape par
étape c'est quoi cette moustache avant
secolo parce que toi y'a que la
moustache qui te choque
non mais le peintre j'adore qu'à moi
c'est exactement ce qu'il me faut ma
mère me gonfle pour que je me remette
avec mon ex femme
on s'est séparé ya moins d'un an quand
on s'est rencontré avec planus et ça y
est sympa ça te remercie procédé
versailles ici en fait
m
les a mais qu'est ce que tu fais là vous
connaissez comme sortis ensemble lycée
je t'aime et avec mon frère tony b je
savais pas que c'était ton frère tu
membres'' pas ben ben c'était vraiment
bizarre d'autres marchés aux parents ah
oui je sais tu va me prendre pour une
folle mais je pense qu'un moyen de
moyenne je signale que tu es censé être
la meuf de son frère du japon va me
manquer de même pas à discuter à t'en
penses quoi toi
thürler chasseurs y as tu te vois un
moulin poire
tu étais où j'étais avec raf je suis
d'accord avec ce que je disais ça sert à
rien de se mentir
y'a pas meilleur que son frère est gay
pour arranger des histoires tu serait
dispo pour un p'tit déj
c'était pas ma belle-soeur ce sera super
plan drague oui c'est à weissach
c'est quoi cette boîte a séduit services
à la personne mais ça cartonne au japon
des chats tu n gage